Thank you for watching!
I don't know what color it is, but I asked for a cake.
What taste is it?
I can't taste anything.
Max likes cream.
Okay, then I'm done.
Take one.
I didn't hear anything.
He hurt himself there.
How did he?
In the week before.
Yeah.
What'd he do?
Hurt himself.
Yeah.
He hurt himself.
I thought he was going to make a trip to his emergency room.
He injured his neck yesterday.
I hate that sport.
I don't know what Willie does.
It's not just watching him.
Even when I watch the other kids wrestle, I'm like, oh, oh.
When you slam them down, that's hurt.
Oh, oh.
Boy, Dirk, you've got quite the colorful cake there.
Colorful character.
One for a certain person.
Even you, I think, thought you'd survive a day, but now you're looking at this.
I'm only looking for things that they call the obvious.
That's the first cake?
Yes.
How's that ice cream, Amanda?
Did you get vanilla?
Oh, there's a trick.
Matches, Dirk.
Oh, there's a photo.
I better get that yellow one in the middle.
That's good.
Get the long.
It's about your cake.
Is it burnt, Dirk?
Can you prove it?
You're as bad as Alec lighting matches.
You know I'm holding right, that's why I get burned.
This one doesn't want light.
You blew out the candles, Mom!
You did, you blew out that one.
I don't know, I think this cake could take years off your life.
That one in the middle I think is fueled by kerosene, I believe.
There's two of them together.
Is that it?
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Dirt!
Oh boy!
I dropped the cake!
Can I move now?
Do we have a...
Do we have a fire alarm?
Fire alarm?
Where's the candles kick at?
Individual candles for Grandma!
Yeah, anyway.
We don't have that many candles.
Hmm.
Aw.
Okay.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Grandma!
my incarceration, I wanna show the nation my appreciation, you my darling, and that's why you should be treated, so you never forget the loving that you needed, yeah, for the love that I call on you needed, begging and pleading, mission completed, yeah, and I said that's all I need is the program, I get up to me surrounded your emotion, yeah, of the feeling that I have for you is so strong, things have been so long and this could never be wrong, you my darling,
I like steady grin, no, he can't get out, when he gets out that four stick it in front of his nose, no, cause he can't get out, night shot, getting a little night, let's see him jump, oh, what was that, he heard that bump and he thought something was going good, he looks like an old bear right there, yeah, he's got this figured out,
you're good, yeah,
2006,
and then what,
and now we are beginning,
team is coming up next,
get ready,
and the ghost of the day,
you're a poor soul,
I know,
bubbles and buttercup,
are in break,
are here to save the world,
all of them,
and more,
rock to music,
the evil brother,
the evil sister,
Uga Uga,
Voldemort,
oh, gosh, I can't name them all,
so, get ready,
some of them might be in this episode,
get ready,
we also have a,
do this whole thing,
because we're trying to cook a meal for the girls,
okay, speaking of the girls,
I was just going shopping to get some food,
okay, I'll see you,
but where are the girls,
where'd they go,
yeah, where did you say,
just about,
about a junk man,
kind of,
aging a those cakes and talking and talking about eating them,
yeah,
but I don't know.
I know you're working that,
I'm a friend of one of your friends,
it was very helpful,
I got your face up.
All right,
we're going to eat,
and you're going Ballad for all of us,
it's gonna be fun.
Do you want some disappointments?
Do you want disappointments?
No,
I want something harder to climb.
oh,
hold on,
hold on baby,
And I want 10 optional parts.
Yes, I did say that.
Where's your bongo box?
Nothing on it.
And I want it to be delivered as soon as possible.
I'll get that.
Where's it from?
Farika's Pizzeria.
Plugs in, Dad.
Okay.
How come I get the little seat?
Okay, now.
Stacy, fly forward.
Air missiles.
Okay, gun one demolished.
Now, I'm going to turn around and you use the sword.
And we'll both use the sword quickly on that other gun.
Last gun.
Um, Stacy, we're finished with the mission.
I know, but it was funny when you blew that last guy up.
What are you doing, Stacy?
Check the mail.
Change mail?
It says, come to the restaurant at 05 tonight.
It says, Paparika.
It says, Pizzeria Disco Club.
It's there, or Disco Club is.
What are you doing?
I thought you were done with all your chores.
Just a workout.
Something I like to do.
Bury my hands.
We have one.
You're on the head, except...
You're in Stacy's concert.
I want you to try to relax.
Stairs.
Ding, ding.
Oh, am I supposed to be behind the door?
Again.
Next blooper.
Why don't you just get out of the stairs.
Here comes the last song.
Hope you like it.
Stairs.